hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with a video review
of the canon 24 millimeter f 1.4 lens
mark ii now let me start off with this
this lens retails for 1
600
i didn't pay a thousand six hundred
dollars for this lens and it's not for
any other legal reasons i actually got
this lens courtesy of borrowlenses.com
you can check out their link in the
description
their service actually allows you to
rent the lens just like a library book
they'll ship it to you and they'll give
you a return shipping label and you can
have this lens for a week for under 100
bucks so if you want to check their
service out that's down below let's go
ahead and take a look at this amazing
lens now like i mentioned before this is
the mark ii version of this lens there
was a mark one version and this mark ii
version actually offers improved image
quality so as you can see you're looking
at test footage of it right now and it
is looking pretty sharp if i might say
myself now something you need to know
about this lens is that it's kind of big
and it's a little bit heavy it actually
weighs more than the canon t2i that i'm
filming with itself now this might be
nice in terms of balance the way you're
carrying it or the way you hold it when
you shoot but it's good to know that
this lens is actually really really big
in fact it dwarfs the kit lens that
comes with the canon t2i that uh 18 to
55 millimeter plastic kit lens it
definitely dwarfs that lens and this is
just a 24mm not that it's compensating
for anything
at all
come on well this lens is good at
everything l lenses should be good at so
the barrel is made of a high quality
material the contacts where it connects
with the camera are made of metal and it
has a very very very high quality glass
inside uh that and it also comes with
this massive lens hood i don't know if
you knew but all l lenses actually come
with a lens hood so that's pretty
convenient this lens is so gigantic and
so wide at 24 millimeters that the glass
inside you can see is actually a little
bit curved uh and in order to get that
full frame effect now distortion has
always been an issue for wide-angle
lenses but i found that on my crop
sensor t2i i really don't get any
distortion at all now autofocus
autofocus on this lens is absurdly good
uh the ultrasonic motor on all the
lenses are fantastic quality they're
silent and they're tack sharp at just
about any exposure and uh if you do want
to do video and do selective manual
focusing the focus ring is actually
really smooth as well i was enjoying the
feel of the focus ring especially when
doing sort of uh in cinematic panorama
shots and all crazy things with the
focus that i do so that that definitely
helped that it was really easy to
manipulate overall this lens is really
good for a youtuber to rent because
number one it's a wide angle lens so i
can sit here in my room and almost be
able to touch the camera and it appears
that it's a pretty wide angle so great
for indoors and number two this is an f
1.4 lens it lets in a massive amount of
light the iris is absolutely gigantic
and it's high quality glass so you're
going to be able to get in
in dim situations and shoot with still a
shallow depth of field i absolutely love
shooting at f 1.4 i reviewed a sigma
lens at f 1.4 not too long ago you can
check that out and i like this lens for
just the same reason absolutely
excellent wide aperture you can even
film like i am right now with no studio
lights so what would i rate this lens
out of 10 well for image quality this
gets a 9 out of 10 only because it does
get a little bit soft at wide angles and
on a full frame body this will be a tiny
bit distorted build quality gets a 10
out of 10 so overall this lens gets a
nine and a half i'd say this is really
close to what you'd get for the price
the price you pay if you pay full price
isn't really worth it but borrowing this
lens you're definitely going to be
impressed with the quality you get out
of it if you're looking for more video
quality tests of this 24 millimeter f
1.4 l series lens besides the
one you're
watching right now you can also view a
pair of link software right here of
videos that i've shot with this lens as
well so definitely great quality lens i
can't say quality is i've said this is a
great quality lens like 12 times in this
video but you get the point thanks for
watching this video review guys and i'll
talk to you guys the next one mkbhd
signing out
peace
what
[Music]
you